aurais tu accélères l'automatisation de
ses magasins aux états unis le plus
grand détaillant du monde ajoutera des
robots bossa nova dans 650 magasins
d'ici l'été
ces robots conçus pour aider au
réapprovisionnement sont déjà présents
dans 350 installations l'avenir du
commerce de détail passe-t-il par la
robotisation égale dan david et
professeur de management de technologie
à le et j'ai eu came to b david bonsoir
bonsoir monsieur fillion wal mart était
dans une phase pilote et là on comprend
est ce qu'on comprend en fait qu'on
passe du projet pilote un projet
beaucoup plus vaste où on veut étendre
l'automatisation des magasins oui alors
ou allemagne le pilote c'est un pilote
qui date quand même 10 à 6 ans parce que
oui on arrive et on voit juste un petit
peu on a l'impression que 50 magasins
c'était un test mais c'est un test qui a
duré longtemps parce que c'est le cleee
le consommateur voit juste la pointe de
l'iceberg le robot qui se balade dans le
dans le magasin mais après six ans
d'études et de raffinement et
d'amélioration aujourd'hui on a des
robots qui actuellement commencent à
être déployés dans 350 650 et dans le
futur certainement dans tous les walmart
équipe en quoi ces robots qui se promène
dans les allées
alors larron
on voit là l'arrière enfin dans le
helmand parce qu'en fait on a devant et
derrière dans les entrepôts il ya des
robots qui pas les tees des palais tease
près par entrepose font la cueillette et
cela qu'on voit ici donc les robots de
bossa nova ben euh c'est des robots qui
se baladent dans les étagères et qui
scanne tout ce qu'ils voient ici pour
regarder le out of stock donc les
produits manquants les produits mal
placé les clients qui prennent un
produit qu'ils déposent ailleurs les
mauvais étiquetage donc ils font un
travail de repérage et surtout une
collègue de données qui va servir à des
analyses en arrière et ses laquais de la
valeur il remplace des employés il
remplace des employés y complète des
employés ils font un boulot qui est
vraiment abrutissant mais les robots ça
les dérange pas alors d'après ce que la
compagnie communiquent ils ne prennent
pas de travail ils ne remplacent pas où
ils ne volent pas de travail lent selon
walmart
mais dans la réalité il ya aussi un
problème c'est que on manque d'employés
qui veulent faire ce genre de boulot à
oui donc en quelque sorte le robot est
le bienvenu il est efficace
les robots aujourd'hui sont très
efficaces
alors on le voit chez walmart mais on le
retrouve partout des robots ils font
c'est à dire que toutes les technologies
ont maturé au point qu'aujourd'hui les
robots sont efficaces ils sont autonomes
ils sont capables de se déplacer tout
seul
ils sont équipés de multi censeurs
d'infrarouge d'ultrasons de caméras
optique de lecteurs rfid donc d'un
ensemble de technologies qui permettra
ces robots de de faire un paquet de
boulot comme cela par exemple chez
amazon voilà alors amazon avait ya c'est
déjà un projet qui remonte à peut-être
dix ans ou amazon avaient fait
l'acquisition de kiva ça c'est des
robots qui sont à l'arrière ce que vous
et moi nous ne voyons pas dans les
entrepôts exactement et ses robots ont
complètement changé les processus
logistiques
ce qu'ils ont fait c'est que
contrairement intérieur qui est une
liste et qui doit aller chercher des
produits bien là le cueilleur est sur
place et c'est les robots qui vont
chercher les produits et qui les ramène
à celui qui fait la cueillette et la
préparation là on voit amazon on parlait
doit au maintien un instant est ce que
wal-mart amazon sont les précurseurs en
cette matière
automatisation robotisation des
installations non c'est pas les
précurseurs en fait
la robotisation elle a commencé déjà
depuis les années 60 avec l'évolution
technologique la mécanique
l'électronique l'informatique la
mécatronique
tout ça nous a emmenés à avoir des
robots comme envoyé dans le milieu
manufacturier
sauf que c'était des robots statique qui
ne faisait qu'un seul travail sous
déplier coupés ils pouvaient pas se
déplacer seul endroit un bras robotisé
pas s'arrêter là et avec les évolutions
technologiques qui ont éclaté au cours
des dernières années les objets autonome
donc ce qu'on a vu c'est que ces robots
ont commencé à se déplacer pour des
activités non pas mono tâche mais
multitâche on est peut-être chez
décathlon ici le décathlon dans le
secteur de la vente au détail
alors décathlon aujourd'hui on essaie
une paire d'espadrilles on l'a on n'a
pas envie de la ramener sur l'étagère on
la balance en dessous d'un banc mais
c'est pas grave
le robot va le savoir parce qu'il se
balade à travers des allées ils vont
scanner les objets et c'est eux qui vont
envoyer l'information aux employés sur
le plancher pour lui dire va prendre tel
espadrilles et va la ramener
l'avenir du commerce de détail
passe-t-il par la robotisation de ses
activités comme ça selon moi non mais
c'est un des outils parmi la boîte à
outils que les entreprises ont
aujourd'hui alors par exemple dans le
cas de décathlon c'est des robots qui
sont équipés de lecteurs rfid
identification par radiofréquence donc
c'est un espèce de code-barres avec
derrière une petite antenne et une puce
mémoire la différence entre le code
barres et rfid le code-barres j'en lis
un à la fois et j'ai besoin d'être en
face du code alors que les tags rfid qui
équipe tous les habits les chaussures
aujourd'hui je peux en dire des
centaines à la fois et ça c'est en train
de révolutionner le secteur de la vente
au détail qui est un grand consommateur
de ce genre de technologie je peux avoir
des robots qui se baladent sur le
plancher je peux avoir des employés avec
un lecteur portable qui balaye font le
travail du robot je peux avoir un
lecteur au plafond qui géolocalise en
temps réel de multiples options
je répète la question de début qu'est ce
qui se passe avec les employés les
employés les employés bah oui on a perdu
jour humaine
oui on a toujours heureuse répondre pop
le robot si aujourd'hui il peut vous
répondre ça veut pas dire qu'on a souri
d'interagir avec un robot pas moi en
tout cas
les générations qui arrivent eux sont
beaucoup plus habitués à ça mais les et
ployer les employés c'est drôle parce
que ça devient un autre employé il ya
quelques années n'ont pas bon il ya
l'année dernière dans le magazine inside
robotics le titre s'était dit bonjour à
votre nouveau collègue
et puis c'est un robot deux autos la
compagnie auto parce que ça devient des
collègues aujourd'hui les robots et donc
les humains font autre chose
les humains font autre chose parfois le
travail des robots collabore avec les
robots le robot va transporter les
objets que les humains ne vont pas
transporter les humains vont faire la
dernière action on voit des grands
magasins ici mais prenez un exemple tout
bête
je suis allé au restaurant manger des
dumplings c'est un robot qui m'a emmené
mon assiette de dumplings bon c'est un
robot monotâche très simple lui
directionnelle qui coûte pas très cher
mais voilà donc on leur fait des bambous
c'était bon c'était bon ok égale
bendavid merci beaucoup
ça fait plaisir intéressant